you got your star on the Hollywood Walk
of Fame that's that's a big deal if we
have a picture of it here did this how
there you go I'm smiling like a
graduation picture you know I've never
seen honey I've never seen you smile
like that I'm extremely happy right now
was that something that you wanted it
have special meaning for you or you've
had so many nice things happen Freda
this one was it special as well in a way
oh yeah it's definitely special
something you don't expect you know I
remember going to school getting bus and
missing the bus have to catch that some
of y'all remember the RTD you know I'm
saying it was our bus rapid transit
district buses whatever the Sultan I
would have to you know go through
Hollywood and walk through Hollywood
Boulevard to catch the next bus so I
would see different people down there
most of the people I didn't know I'm
like who the hell is that yeah but then
you know some people you were recognized
and it was kind of cool but you never I
never thought in a million years that
you know somebody I walk at my stars say
who the hell is that
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you had a pretty good did you get a good
location you liked your location it's
pretty cool is right in front of uh I
think like a Music Museum I'm glad that
he put me in front of like the liquor
store dispensary or something like yeah
yeah or the women's shoes and yen sizes
yeah yeah like you've been on huh then
if you ever noticed the women's shoes in
men's sizes store you have not been on
Hollywood Boulevard because that's what
that place why are you going there all
the time they're going there right cube
let's pull this back man it's just nice
to know they're there in case I need him
all right cube he's working stuff he's
working stuff out yeah the same thing
he's working stuff out listen I'm fine I
am work so you got a good location you
get a good turnout for your ceremony oh
yeah yeah man it was everybody there it
was that's what's cool about it you know
I had a chance to to let people know
that that you know I still remember him
I still think about them people think
when you you know get to a certain part
in show business or whatever you you
stop thinking about people that really
helped you get here and it was cool to
just shot shout out people that that I
knew didn't think I was even thinking
about right see you Dave gave you gave
respect to people who helped you every
every step of the ladder every step of
the way
I was calling out everybody yeah I was
shouting out people David some of them
ain't even here no more so it's kind of
cool
you